police officers in the northeastern
state of Assam ensure everyone abides by
the lockdown but has restrictions
continue to be enforced for most people
to limit the spread of the corona virus
after being locked up for some prisoners
are enjoying their release ten-year-old
Sahana doe was just 15 days old when her
mother minara begum was declared an
illegal foreigner from neighboring
Bangladesh and sent to a detention
center
aheh Nara went with her I'm happy now
once I go home I'll meet my brother
sisters and father I only saw them once
in an interview ahah nada and her mother
a two of at least 60 people who've been
released from detention centers for
undocumented migrants in Assam after a
Supreme Court order to reduce
overcrowding in prisons during the
corona virus outbreak hundreds of
mother's like them remain imprisoned
lawyers say many of them were wrongfully
detained and couldn't prove their
citizenship because of issues such as
discrepancies in the spelling of their
name and different documents all of
these are small spelling mistakes small
errors that the tribunal doesn't believe
any more the members don't take them as
mistakes many who are declared
foreigners are actually not foreigners
that all Indian citizens but because of
these minor errors they're now suffering
in now gone destruct the Hart family are
happy to have Aziz all back after he
spent three years and their school
detention center perfectly there was 60
to 65 people living in a room in the
detention camp when I first got there
there were around 150 to 350 people
living in a room there was about a
hundred square meters 42 year-old heart
like many others didn't have all the
papers to prove his citizenship even
though he was born in India in many
instances people who are facing
detention of deportation largely
because they do not have documents to
show that their parents or even the
grandparents their Indian
last year nearly two million of the
state's 35 million population were left
off a National Register of citizens a
government campaign to check illegal
immigration from neighboring Bangladesh
while their legal status is in limbo
the government started building
detention centers plans for a nationwide
register of citizens provoked protests
as did the citizenship Amendment Act
which fast-tracked citizenship to
minorities from neighboring countries
but excludes Muslims India's lockdown
ended months of protests and also began
the release of some prisoners but rights
groups say only five people declared
illegal migrants in the past seven years
have been deported activists are asking
the government to uphold international
law which says detention must end when
there's little or no prospect of
deportation Elizabeth puranam al Jazeera
New Delhi